let's start Who am I my name is Juan and
normally from nine to six they call me a
software engineer Butera
at level which is our dating up in
Germany however today I would like to
scratch this title and I want to be a
Pokemon data master why is that well
because into the representation which is
titled detecting Pikachu on Android and
more you see in terms of low audio
detection I'm going to be talking about
Pokemon and Dana so please enjoy relax
it's a really cool presentation so enjoy
so now first question and please do not
disappoint me
what is this no answers yet what is this
exactly perfect so speak as you yellow
mouth red cheeks we love it however what
about computers they do not know what is
a big machine right if I go now to my
computer and I'm like hey what is this
it's not gonna say anything because
computers do not talk so they are pretty
ignorant about Pikachu's and this makes
me unhappy
because we know what is Pikachu and
computers and devices they do not know
so my goal here with this experiment is
this I want to close this gap of
ignorance I want to teach computers what
a Pikachu is but before I start since
this is about Pikachu an object
detection let's take a small example
that's because you write and that's a
really nice green box meaning that this
is indeed one Pikachu so this is my
agenda for today I'm going to divide
this presentation into three main parts
first I'm going to be talking a bit
about theory because it's always nice to
know what's going on under the hood then
also I'm going to explain you guys how I
build my own costume detection system
for pick a shoe and then even cooler how
I am using this oil so let's turn now
what is object detection well I like to
define object detection as the process
of recognizing instances of an object in
images or video in any frame however I'm
really sure that maybe some of you may
be back there is asking hang on what is
the different between object action and
image classification and that's a really
really nice question my dear friend and
the answer is this or my own answer so
here we have two images right
because you and the object detection
let's suppose that we have the best
pocket exit we have the best Pokemon
detection classifier classification
sorry that we fit one image and the
opposite going to the Pikachu right
really straightforward X image why
because you
however in object detection the goal is
more granular here we want to know
something even more than just knowing
that it's a Pikachu
here I want to know exactly where my
Pikachu is located and this is nice
because maybe you have the use case of
you want to know the relation of this
object from the other one for example
it's because you on top below besides
this also maybe we want to know how many
Pikachu's I have and here we can see
that we had like two different labels
because you pick a shoe indeed to pick a
[ __ ] one and two perfect however on the
other image let's suppose that we have a
thousand Pikachu the output is still
going to be Pikachu right but we would
know exactly how many Pikachu's I have
so doesn't mean different here is more
granular is more specific and here is
just like yes ossification and it's the
same whether you say and how did I build
this like how did I did my system and I
use them so Flavia detection API which
is tens of lose answer to the detection
problem and this library is really
really cool and the best part is that it
is able to Train accuracy for speed and
memory consumption meaning that we are
able to make our system a little bit
more weak in terms of accuracy however
is going to be even better instead of
speed and memory consumption meaning
that we will able to deploy it in weak
devices such as models and why is this
well this is due to the fact that the
package includes many many many visual
extractor sorry and architectures and we
are able to play around with them we can
choose this architecture or we can use
this extractor and we keep playing
around with then we might able to find
the right balance between speed and
accuracy so now let's start
get some paper recommend maybe so no you
want to take some notes and let's talk
about how I built my own detection
system
first of course we need to install
tensorflow I'm really sure that most of
you already have it but more than that
we also need to clone the repo called
models meaning that we have to go into
terms of log github you have to look for
the Rubicon models and you're going to
clone that 1 3 4 right
but next we need to create our dataset
so simply just get a bunch of images I
use around 230 and 80% of them which is
from training and they reminders 20%
were used to ever rate and I try to be
as diverse as possible you know
try using pikachu's from the cars from
the anime from different season of the
anime of the anime fan art and so on
also I try to get different position of
Pikachu but let's be honest Pikachu sir
it's a fake yellow Mouse so every time
somebody's going to draw it it's going
to focus on a night hey perfect it's
working
nope yeah perfect okay so as I was
saying every single time someone is
going to draw Pikachu is going to focus
on the main features which are the red
cheeks the tail and the ear so it was
quite hard to get other angles of my
dear Pikachu so after that we have to
label our dataset and the process of
labeling here is quite different than
what we are used to why because here
we're dealing with object detection so
we need to tell our system hey this is
my object and the main idea here using
one of the many software that are
available for doing this is that you are
going to draw a bounding box surrounding
your Pikachu and this takes a lot of
time is really boring to cut rotate your
mouth load the image draw click and then
you need to write the name
Pikachu so please just do some extra Sun
shields for a financial because you are
going to need it because this is really
really boring so every time you label
one image this is going to output an XML
file which is going to contain the name
of your image the name of your object
and the coordinate of your object which
in this case is these tiny box that we
have here but tensorflow
it does not deal with XML tensorflow is
like and the heck is this I don't like
XML so we need to transform this into a
format
similar that tears of loss nose and this
one is called TF record and the wrap-up
it already contains all the code the
script that you need to do this you
simply need to specify where are your
XML and this is going to output one nice
file called TF record and I have this
script also in my github I'm going to
present the link at the very end so
every time I talk about script or code
believe me it's going to be on github so
don't worry so a lot then there's
something else that we need and it's
called the label map and the level map
is simply one really tiny file that
contains the ID of your item and the
name of your object in the sky in my ID
is number one and my object is pick a
shoe please keep in mind to know use ID
zero because that number is research so
so far let me briefed a bit so I talked
about how to install tensor flow and
what exactly we need I talked about how
we have to create the dataset how to
label the dataset
followed by creating the TF record file
and the label map now let's move on to
something more interesting how do we
train this because this is the the good
part so the training here is based on
one amazing file is called let's call it
the pipeline and in the pipeline you
specify everything regarding your
training now this file it is divided
into five different sections the first
one of them is called model and in model
we're going to specify the architecture
which is my obvious detection
architecture that I would like to use
we also specifies the feature extractor
and the loss function then we have
training config and in training config
we're going to write about the number of
epochs that we want to use for our
training the size of my badge and a
training checkpoint then we have the
Train input reader and evaluation
input reader are here we specify where
is our training set and our evaluation
set and lastly there is evil config and
here we're going to write the number of
example that we want to use to evaluate
our model now this file here looks quite
simple but in reality is really really
complex - a measure of 180 images
however tens of wrote they're socialized
guy so they are
a provider with a huge list of example
config files that we can use so we don't
have to spend hours and they just like
tweaking all these little numbers like
training whatever I dealt and I'll
follow this small thing that we'll use
for the renewal we don't have to do this
they already did it for us
so instead of spending hours doing this
just go there just find one and just
play around with it so now how do we run
this well there is another script in the
report is called train dot PI and we're
simply going to call this script and
we're going to use as a parameter the
path to my training directory which is
the directory where you have the TF
record and the label map and then you
also need to specify where is your PI
plan file but now before moving on I
start talking about this and continue
talking about this I wanted to make a
small stop and talk about with
architecture i am using because like I
say theories of it nice so the
architecture I use is called SSD we
stand for single detection single shot
detection and it is called single shot
detection because it's going to predict
the class of my object and its location
during the same shot the opposite of
this is an architecture that require a
second component name the proposal
generator to predict the position of the
box and this is an image from the
official paper that describes the
library and can we have three different
architectures SSD faster are CNN and RFC
n and we can see that here there's only
one box after the feature extractor
because everything is going to be
performed in one single shot while the
orders - they have like two different
boxes
I know it's quite hard to block the
concept so if you guys are more
interested in this this is thinning of
the paper is really amazing and awesome
I have a copy somewhere so if someone
was to take a look feel free to ask me
but now let's move on how do I ever like
this I'm training how do I know Lee my
mother is going to be an amazing one or
a really boring and shitty one so they
already provide another script called
evaluation Python and when you execute
this script this is going to calculate a
lot of different metrics
regarding your model and the one I use
personally is called that
I lost because it's obvious is always
nice to see the loss and also one use
Pascal vo c m AP mean average precision
however how do we see this it's like
yeah we're calculating all of this but
we want to see them right so some of you
might know that tensor flu has a
component called tensor board which is
its web UI which can be used for a lot
of different reasons and it is also
available for this project we can seat
and support to see the performance of
the model and this is an example of how
it looks like there is like a thousand
of photons pretty graph and so on so
you're feel free to play around with it
but even even better is that we can see
the process of our training right here
in tensor board meaning that we are able
to see the detections rider and even
cooler here just a slider and this
lighter is going to move through every
single checkpoint of my training so we
can evaluate our training for example in
epoch thousand in epoch 2009 87 so and
it's really nice because when you start
from the first one no matter you don't
have any boxes but you can see how the
boxes are going to like but to show up
meaning that your model and your
training is indeed working and how do we
run this really simple we run this ever
ever lit dot Python and we use the same
parameter that we used before we have to
repeat some of the lights running the
rectory and checkpoint directories are
normally the same one and how do we run
test football well we just call test or
board and then we saying as a parameter
they pass to my training directory so
now training is over is nice we are
happy with it but now what we need to
freeze this model we want to use it so
doing every single checkpoint tensorflow
is going to create three files and they
end in the extension dot data dot index
dot meta but this is a lot of
information like I don't want three
files in my pocket you know it's one one
so further we have to freeze our model
and they already provide one file called
export inference graph and when we call
this file we're going to specify which
is the number or my checkpoint that I
want to use you see what I have here
this X X X X X so we're going to write
the shape point that we want to freeze
and
after this you're going to have one file
called frozen inference graph and this
my friends this is what you want this is
what you want to keep in your USB Google
Drive Dropbox or send it to your mom
this is our mother so please take care
of it but now let me take another small
break to breathe I say I'm going quite
fast so I'm going to slow down so so far
I have to a couple have to train our
system the whole pipeline file we need
air we specify the model and so on then
I talk about the architecture I'm using
SSD or single shot detection then how do
we evaluate our model followed by these
how to freeze our model but now the cool
part how do we use this my model is
perfect I want to impress my friends I
want to impress all of you guys so the
first use case that I tried was a really
simple one images right and in the repo
there's already a Python notebook which
has most of the code that we need for
this again and the only thing you need
to change let's say your stone really
specific like where is your frozen model
what is the ratio the confidence ratio
that you would like to use also maybe
you want to change the color of the box
no we do not like green do you want it
yellow but because yellow so that's not
a good decision and so on and this is an
example of how the code looks like I'm
respecting you guys to see this really
far but just to give a small idea of
what's going on here so first of course
we need to load our image then then we
need to convert our image into an array
representation using non pipe then we
are going to run the tensorflow section
on this and this is going to return
three main things the one is the box if
there's one box what is the coordinate
on my detection box followed by lid we
have this score
what is there my confidence score house
sure I on that this is indeed one
Pikachu and not one yellow blob also the
glass what is my class speakers or is it
zero is knowledge nothing then we call
this function call visualize boxes and
label on image array using this
parameter and this is the result
detection process and Pikachu's here we
can see five different Pikachu's
we can see that the one in the middle is
a force
because indeed that's a big castle but
like I mentioned earlier I couldn't find
so many images of we're angles of
Pikachu and in such cases it's not going
to get detected but we can see in this
case I really like this one because we
see Pikachu with two pigeons and I've
seen the prediction in my opinion is
really clean because the box is try what
it should be is not getting so much of
the P issue and the the worst case is
another who have been a detection of the
whole image and here we can see because
should sleep in because you happy and
teenage Pikachu so now on Android so how
do we do this on Android so first of
course we need to get the Android demo
Pro unit from terms of flow so please
now we need to clone the tenth of
floripa not the modest one they want
from the official tends to flow one and
somewhere there's other I took other a
directory called Android this is what we
need also we're going to need Android
studio so get ready to install another
IDE injure computer so now we need to
import the project so we're going to
under studio important to create and
we're going to select the directory
I mentioned 27 seconds ago this one
Android remember and here in overall our
goal is going to be to install the demo
app however however there's once well
like as some changes that we want to do
to the actual Java code we want to
specify words our model once again and
then maybe we want to change the the
confident threshold so we need to play
around with it a tiny bit also we need
to build and compile our project I'm not
sure if some of you know about Android
but normally you do this using Gradle
they already provide the Gradle file you
only need to click the green hammer
button and it's going to build however
by default at least when I did it
there is one variable called native
build system and by default it is set to
none if you keep it by known the project
is going to run but you won't get the
dependency so maybe your own app your
app is going to crash so please make
sure that you use all any of the other
options are already provide for bit in
the project which are they still make
file or female
and then everything is ready we built
the pro yet let's make the magic happens
so we go into this really cool bar we
play day we click the green play button
and if we are lucky our place by the way
make sure your device is connected
really important and if we are lucky we
are going to have a nice up line however
I was not that lucky
Danton Tom three seconds of silence
errors errors errors angry faces I have
no idea how many bad words I said this
my dear friends this six ways of looking
at this and as far as I could understood
what really what this mean of this bla
bla bla bla bla is that there is one
operation or one node in my frozen model
that is not available on the Android
side what I was like what so I tried a
lot of things first of course I make
sure that is the same version even the
same committee version fold on my
project and didn't work I went to hip
hop I did an issue nothing a lot of
people commented yeah the same no
solution so overflowed the same six
weeks I was like Jesus Christ it was
almost like Christmas I was home
drinking pina coladas and just thinking
about Pikachu's undies and it was really
frustrating I was about just like to
throw everything away and that's it but
then one day one day after the pina
colada I went home I went to that cold
and I took a look at the file the script
I used for freezing the model because to
be honest since they already provide the
file the script
you don't have to write anything so you
just run it under seed and deep inside
you know like so deep inside the code
there is one function i hit only
remember the name and he has this
variable
it's called optimize graph and by
default is set to true and I was like I
don't want to optimize anything you know
I was really angry that there was I do
not want to optimize I want the mother
raw the way it should be the way terms
of love did wrong with our optimization
so I just went to the variable I put my
mouse in the words room I did bucks five
bucks five bucks a box paid four times
because through is four letters and then
I wrote a half a LSE Falls the
I've lost my model I took it again I
went to Android and guess what happened
it works today I still have no clue what
that happened I'm not smart enough to
know exactly why but at least do not
optimize your model okay because it's
not gonna work on Android and you see
how it looks look how beautiful it looks
this in my app this is a Pokemon car I
have here on the back of my phone
it's my example for a bit impressing my
friends and we can see that detection is
quite cool here we have another
screenshot and we have five detection at
the same time this one it wasn't
detected but come on I got like five out
of six I think it's nice so it works
it's nice but however let's be honest
I'll be really honest with you because I
like you guys I was not so happy you
know I was not so happy I was like high
school but I feel like it could be
better you know I feel like the Android
side was kind of weak there was a lot of
false positive because you know detected
it was really slow so I was expecting
something more I was not proud of myself
so what I decided to improve a tiny beat
my pro yet so I had a 70 more images
this thing I really tried to get more
sight images of Pikachu
then I extended my training for another
5000 a box and lastly this like come fix
ashamed the detection threshold on the
Android app 2.85 and it was it was very
was better so now I have a new model and
I want to try it with something new I
was like oh god spoilers really I wanted
to do something new on the next use case
was like guess what videos and it was
like you know I want to do this on
videos also the western of the
recommendation that shown that some
people gave me after the first time I do
did you play a Pokemon episode of and
get all the Pikachu's and it was like I
still got to it so I did it now this is
once again an example of the code it's
really similar to the previous one
however I would like to point out two
main difference first is that instead of
loading one image full we have to load
their video of course then we have to
iterate through every single frame of my
video and we're going to capture that
frame and
we're going to treat this frame as my
image then taking this frame we're going
to get all the detection and this is
going to return well a copy of the frame
but with the detection now I have one
object here called be the writer and in
this pedo writer you are going to fill
it with all these new frames so it's
going to create a new video based on
your friends with stop detection and get
some popcorn because I'm going to show
you an example it's only one minute long
so enjoy it because you live ketchup
there we go oops
something wrong what is happened no
Pikachu detected that's awful
all guy talking oops because she's
bought detected classic big there we go
oh that's nice oh come on no detection
that's sad nothing is perfect
ash talking yeah it is angry like always
I'm broke is just been broke but then
Ton Ton Ton oh there we go
Pikachu how's the cat your buddy spider
want some ketchup oh my god cash was
broken whoop mistakes and now because
she's sad because he has no ketchup
bottle so sorry buddy so now results no
results so in overall the main issue
here is the number of false positive are
we saw in the video site there was the
text it's like a mouse item is green
what's going on tensorflow so for me
that was like a big letdown also once
again is that the Android are still it
feels better but I still feel like I
could do a little bit more work Sony in
overall if I compare the Android with
the order to they're quite weak and when
I show an example there when during the
question so you guys can play around if
you want but now conclusion in overall
I'm quite happy and pleased with the
result I mean I have my own Pikachu
detection system even on my phone and it
is enough to impress but is here your
friends I'm gonna Pokemon freaks and
maybe your mom you're carrying on all of
you guys
also you know it's been quite nice and
interesting to play around this feel of
deep learning just something different
and also I'm here speaking to all of you
today which is quite cool so for the
future I would like to keep improving my
training set maybe to use more images or
like non frontal images of Pikachu maybe
try another configuration of my feature
extractor on architecture because the
one I use is like the weakest one
because I this time I want a better
performance instead of memory and speed
because I really really wanted to have
it on my phone and I'm sure that if I
try some of the most complex architects
you are going to get a better result but
maybe I won't be able to run it on my
phone and also I would like to add a
second class just to make it more
interesting so maybe Charmander so
that's it like thanks for your time here
I have all my info I have my medium
block just in case you guys would like
to know more there I have like two
articles describing these with every
single detail so feel free to read at it
you have any question please ask me a
lot of people have wrote me like hey man
my mother is not working people that are
having the same issue the thing I say
with Android and I tell them the same do
not optimize your model so it's quite
nice really and yeah I've seen the C
credit to the son of the icons I use and
thank you
[Applause]
so there's plenty of time for some
questions but I'm gonna steal the first
one so effectively you you are now
building a pokedex kinda okay yeah I
just out of curiosity because the the
model for just Pikachu how big is that
how big it really really small it is I
think it's around 20 megabytes I have
its own web bodies I have it all on
github and I'd get home it does not
allow such a big files first really tiny
but if you would like actually try to
make the Pokedex for the first 150 folks
if it's going to grow that if I can
really answer that right now I'll have
to have to write Billy with Charmander
then I'll send you an email I hey this
is now the size of the model so I am
assuming is going to grow but I thought
I can't really tell you by how much it's
going to grow fair enough let's have all
the pokemon readers questions
yeah meanwhile I'm going to set the
visor here you want to do a demo not on
me but well you guys asked I just want
to have this running here quickly what
you feel free to ask me
thanks for all the Pikachu's I have
asked about Charmander but your sensor
that thank you did your training sets
also contain photos of nothing like no
Pikachu's or did you know like all of
them were Pikachu yeah to be honest I
just wanted to make it run sorry I'm
just like focusing okay this is an
Pikachu
I I could have tried just like to have
images with no label to see if the model
performs better but I was just focusing
like managers you speak as you want does
it how often does your model matches
righteous or [ __ ] okay righteous I
have never seen a right you but I have
here an example with Pichu if my app
starts to work so I can actually show it
to you but it's actually like with
speeches it happens sometimes because
maybe like the color palette is quite
similar to the singers Pikachu the same
color but right you oh my god is sooner
but as I show is more like Orangery so
maybe does not detect that yeah I mean
with tragedy had never happened
but with picture with hobbies like all
the time I have here the feature to show
you both as always the demo is not
working now we have 5 minutes so you can
wait ok well question I suppose I have
have you tried just putting a picture of
a yellow blob yeah I have it here but
indeed it does not get detected okay any
other questions
yeah just feel free to ask well like
there's another question alive thrower
here with my how is the practicality of
having models like that on Android
phones because it seems I'm an Android
dev and it seems it laughs it loads a
lot of battery memory RAM for instance
an app is usually about 50 megabytes it
shouldn't be more than that the rice
paper starts uninstalling them so how
far are we to having actually tensorflow
as something that can actually be
included in any yet so I think that was
to really answer that question as you
have to train with the other
architectures because like I said I used
the weakest one and it was ok I don't
have any issues but I really would like
to try the other one so I can made the
difference from my own experience I can
tell you that if not like my phone gets
hot or anything na means it's also like
a pixel too so it's quite fine however
like is I don't see any really bad
improving on the battery or the phone
getting slow like it works the way it
should be but I cannot do it on purpose
like I wanted to use the weakest
architecture so I'll have to try it with
the most intense architecture and then I
acting like I will able to other thought
that question anyone else
I think everyone's really keen on seeing
a demo yes so it's a lot it is connected
right oh there's a question
oh there it is what I'm going to get now
one AD because this is my phone
hopefully I won't get any weird Jesus
Lord
ooh demo time yeah see anything there's
a flow detect so Pikachu right phone
camera and now since not everything is
positive in life then what's positive
Pikachu
it's not Pikachu is pitch you and here
I'll come on man really it's a bit slow
like I said so we need some time oh boy
failure but this one is better yeah more
Pikachu
hey so sweet it's fun it's nice to have
some laughs and to try wrong with it so
we have to give him like one round of
applause just for that anyone oh there
is one more question and after that we
will switch thank you uh thank you for
talking about you talking about models
and models different structures and use
the tensor flow but away what are you
that crease model that you use in the
tint flow as deep learning or just
traditional dr. which I know that
question was coming so I have fun
appendix here
so did I pay to watch my mouth my mom my
mouth yeah come on really so the future
destructor we are actually like
continent the vehicle convolution of
feature extractor and they want to use
komova in it and it's basically just a
neural network which is going to get the
features of your object and here this is
like a screenshot from the actual
specification
the default one I used and as you can
see it talks about layers and side of
layers activation functions are so on so
this really just like a Moodle network
it's just like a fancy name in the same
way we have like Alex Nate and Google
Ned and so on then we have mobile in it
and then there's only one Orca like
Inception they really have like
fastenings is this one yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's called more than that I'm
mobile because it's quite weak in
compared to the other which are like
Inception version to Inception version
three so they have like more harsh name
we could say and this is just like movin
it no but really a lot like if you
actually read the specification in the
papers you can see there big difference
like orders they're like big bigger and
bigger net word that you sly more rigid
hyperparameters and so on and this one
is more like more relaxed we could say
then we can all remember today that he
was still here not yet the millionaire
because he hasn't made the Pokedex yet
but I'm sure but I was gonna come one
this was amazing thank you
[Applause]